the biggest wow streamer on twitch has
started playing that game's most serious
competitor
final fantasy 14. and honestly
it's been insane huge personal
viewership as well as an exploding
player base within the game itself
developer square enix even had to
temporarily stop selling digital copies
of the game
and you add to that a wow expansion
that's been fairly criticized by many of
even its
longtime supporters and things
could get a little crazy
[Music]
did you know that the critically
acclaimed mmorpg final fantasy 14 has a
free trial that includes
oh sorry that's the wrong throw but i
think you know i'm gonna ask
please like the video hit the subscribe
button and ring the notification bell so
we can continue to bring you new content
and remember
to calm those dps that are pumping we
exist
so what do you get when the biggest wow
streamer out there decides
he's gonna play another mmo before asmin
gold
actually did it no one was quite sure
because
well final fantasy 14 is actually a
pretty different game
this guy's weird to be clear aspen gold
has played other games but wow has
always been his first mmo love it's what
made him
basically a streaming celebrity on
twitch outside of wow asthma gold is a
constant presence in streaming more
generally
appearing on panel shows and getting
into it on twitter
like when a now deleted tweet from a
blizzard employee expressing some
negativity reached his eyes he also
co-founded one true king with
other big streamers like miss kiff s fan
and rich campbell
and now his massive fan base has sent
shockwaves through the final fantasy xiv
community
and made it one of the fastest growing
games in the world
nearly a decade after its release but
before we get into that
let me give you a bit of context here
world of warcraft has been around for
nearly 17 years and its most recent
expansion sent players
to the literal afterlife to chase after
genocidal banshee queen sylvanas
windrunner
who you may know for burning down an
entire tree filled with hippy elves
final fantasy xiv on the other hand
is a game that suffered a terrible
initial launch in 2010
dropped a literal moon on the planet in
2013 and then
started fresh after a redesign led by
producer naoki yoshida
it's actually a crazy story and one that
i personally hope to be able to tell you
guys on the channel one day
by yoshida's own admission wow's design
played an important part in the
decisions he made to salvage the game
but despite both being mmorpgs and
one's design being heavily influenced by
the other
both games are pretty different wow is
the undisputed
champion of that initial mmorpg rush
people kept looking for the wow killer
but it turned out that wow
survived all of its challengers the
game's philosophy in those early days
was simple
give players a lot of content and then
release new content
when it becomes needed eventually to
allow returning players and
friends to play the most recent content
easily
that new content made the old content
kind of pointless like yeah you can go
back
and wow and do an old raid but there's
not really a point because
typically you can get the same quality
of gear from that normal raid
from just quests in this new content
patch
final fantasy xiv took a different
approach it would actually sync your
character's
level to the content that your character
was doing so
it was always relevant and in addition
to that
the progress that you had made over
previous patches wasn't just
annihilated by new content in wow a
substantial amount of the story actually
happens
in those raids that i mentioned so you
kind of have to do them
if you want to see what happens in the
story in
14 the story is mandatory for everyone
and
it's largely a solo experience even the
story released in patches
is woven together to create a continuous
narrative
and the music writing and atmosphere in
the game are
in my opinion all incredibly high
quality
okay but how does asmongold fit into all
this
well he's been one of the voices
critical of blizzard's recent design
decisions
and he's been looking to branch out into
other mmos
so his decision to play 14 has just
generated
interest for the game and there's been
rising dissatisfaction with world of
warcraft for a while
the game's content strategy is basically
the same as it was
back in wrath of the lich king new patch
comes out you do the dungeons and the
raid
and then you wait for the automated
content feeding machine to feed you
another pellet
in 6 to 12 months and
if you didn't touch the old pallet just
throw it away
because it's not worth eating them in
addition to that the community has grown
alongside streaming many of the top
players in the world's best guilds have
become
content creators and the race to world
first
where the top guilds compete to clear
the newest raid on mythic difficulty
is always a big event on twitch that
community has tried to give blizzard
feedback to help them
understand the issues with the game
often dealing with the newly added
expansion features
and offered well in advance of the
expansion's
actual release but much of that feedback
has been
seemingly disregarded in the past so
some of these vocal content creators
have become increasingly critical of
blizzard
this disillusionment was put into the
spotlight recently in carbot animation's
excellent
this is world of warcraft video where
the once vibrant social landscape of the
game
is replaced by a cold unfeeling content
treadmill
and carbot is another great example of a
creator who
was even paid to make official skins for
a blizzard game
starcraft remastered but is now voicing
their own sort of critique
or at least lament to blizzard
and it just so happens that asmingold is
one of those vocal critics
and while he says he still loves the
game and just wants it to be better
asmingold may have done the only thing
that can truly frighten blizzard
exposing their player base to a new mmo
one where their time on the content
treadmill is not
instantly forgotten the moment a new
patch comes out
imagine going to work for a company
that's made one of the most
monumental and biggest flagship games
in history that has been one of the only
recent running games that has been
inducted into the video games hall of
fame
world of warcraft is iconic and then you
ruin it
imagine that imagine ruining that
the biggest wow streamer playing the
game's number one competitor is simply
something that had to happen eventually
but the timing couldn't be worse for wow
though patch 9.1
just came out it took like 8 months for
it to release
and the patch disregarded player
feedback about many of the core systems
in the expansion
while pushing the story of sylvanas in a
potentially controversial direction
but again there's a new dungeon and a
new raid
we'll see you again in 6 months if
you're lucky
the only thing more surprising than
asman's decision to play final fantasy
14
is that it honestly seems like he's
genuinely
enjoying it
oh [ __ ]
oh no man
and in addition to the quality
entertainment it's also given his
fans and final fantasy 14 players alike
some pretty great memes lisa lamassa
prides itself on being auresia's
foremost naval power gaslata oh that's
her name
sure there have been some issues like
players trying to grief asman by using
massive mounts to block important npcs
although after square enix started
handing out suspensions for this
it pretty much stopped imagine if you
went to a foo fighters concert
and every single time that dave girl
tried to play a new song
someone drives their car into the set
it's like get your
get get your mustang out of the way
but get it out of the way we're trying
to listen to the band asmin gold's first
stream on july
3rd for final fantasy 14 did really well
averaging about 145 000 concurrent
viewers
and the game's player base has continued
to explode so much so in fact that
square enix is starting to take notice
and to take action though most pc
players
don't play the game through steam the
game did hit a concurrent user record
there
the game itself also recently hit 22
million registered players
and then on monday july 12th the windows
version of the game
was unavailable to purchase through
square enix
meaning that if you wanted a copy you
had to buy it on steam
the playstation store or for mac they
also restricted new character creation
on
every north american server for a short
period of time on monday
there were clear server load issues and
then on
tuesday night most na servers again were
restricted
though most players have seen
restrictions like this in rare cases
to see it affect every server and not
surrounding the launch of
any content at all was pretty wild
now while asmingold is still playing 14
he said that he plans to play even more
mmos including ashes of creation but
beyond that it seems like he's still
pulling for wow
and hoping that they can fix many of the
issues that the community wants to see
addressed
blizzard on suicide watch nah the thing
is blizzard should not be on suicide
watch
blizzard should be on like rebirth what
but for the moment
final fantasy 14 is the game reaping the
rewards
my opinion is that this game respects
your time and encourages you to be
social and friendly with other players
including new players who are called out
with a sprout icon
by the way if you're mean to a sprout if
you're mean to my little cinnamon roll
in final fantasy xiv you're a piece of
[ __ ]
and with this surge in popularity
interest in
other mmos has already started to spread
variety streamer co
carnage and otk founder rich campbell
have already started to play 14
while shroud and summit 1g have started
to play one of my old favorites
star wars the old republic so where do
we go from here
final fantasy 14 has an expansion
launching in november
while wow's next patch has no current
release date
i'm happy that asmin's attention to this
game has brought new eyes to it
and i'm sure that will spill over to the
other mmos that he chooses to play
but i have a sneaking suspicion that the
humans and orcs
in asman gold's fan base might enjoy
being a cat girl
a little more than they thought and if
you're a fan of
wow and this entire thing is worrying
you
maybe think of it as a potential wake-up
call for the developers
to put the game back on track and listen
to the community's feedback
like i like alluding that if you play an
mmo you're basically like a [ __ ] lab
rat
because like it's kind of true it's kind
of true like you're kind of on the
treadmill i don't want to let down the
team in wow right so
instead i just let them down completely
by being like i'm not playing this game
and then they don't have any
expectations for me you know that's good
i got this
lim's mentality now dude i i don't hang
out in limsa dude
like i hang out in a different city but
that's where all the like really
the cat girls the dragon girls the bunny
girls
the tiny potato girls what other kind of
girls are there there's just girls like
regular human girls there's elf girls
very rare elf girls